Dear fellow scholars.
This is two minute papers with Dr. [inaudible] through the power of news.
On that work-based learning algorithms today.
It is possible to perform video to video translation.
This means that for instance,
in goes a daytime video and outcomes and nighttime version of the same
footage. This previous method had some remarkable properties. For instance,
look,
you can even see the reflections of the nightlights appearing on the car hood.
This is reassuring news, indeed,
because the spark of some sort of intelligence was already there in these
algorithms. And believe it or not, this is old,
old news because we have been able to do these for about three years now,
of course, this was not perfect. The results were missing. A lot of details.
The frames of the video were quite a bit apart.
Artifacts were abandoned and more,
but this paper was a huge leap at the time.
And today I wonder how far have we come in three years?
What can we do now that we were not able to do three years ago?
Let's have a look together. This input video is much more detailed,
a lot more continuous. So I wonder what we could do with this. Well,
hold onto your papers. And woo.
Look at that one.
We have changed a sky and put a spaceship in there that is already
amazing. But look to the spaceship is not stationary,
but moves in harmony with the other objects,
individual and three, since the sky has changed,
the lighting situation has also changed.
So the colors of the remainder of the image also have to change.
Let's see the before and after on that, yes. Excellent.
And we can do so much more with this, for instance,
put a castle in the sky or you know what let's
think big, make it an extra planet, please. Wow.
Thank you. And wait a minute.
If it is able to recolor the image after changing its surroundings,
how well does it do it? Can we change the background to a dynamic one?
What about a thunderstorm? Oh yeah.
That's as dynamic as it gets and a new method handles this case beautifully.
And before we look under the hood to see how all this wizardry is done,
let's list our expectations. One,
we expect that it has to know what picks us to change,
to load a different sky model to it should know how the image is
changing and rotating over time.
And three summary coloring has to take place.
Now let's have a look and see if we find the parts we are expecting.
And yes, it has a sky mapping network.
This finds the parts of the image where the sky is.
There is the motion estimator that computes the optical flow of the image
distracts the movement of the sky over time.
And there is the recoloring module as well. So there we go.
This can do not only scary placement,
but detailed weather and lighting synthesis is also possible for these videos.
One at a time to be alive. Now, if you remember, first,
we looked at the results, listed our expectations,
and then we looked at the architecture of this neural network.
This is a technique that I try to teach to my students in my lab,
transport simulation course at the technical university of Vienna.
And I think if you check it out, you will be surprised by how effective it is.
Now note that I was always teaching it to a handful of motivated students.
And I believe that the teachings shouldn't only be available for the privileged
few who can afford a college education,
but the teaching should be available for everyone free education for
everyone. That's what I want.
So the course is available free of charge for everyone, no strings attached.
So make sure to click the link in the video description to get started.
We ride a full light simulation program from scratch there and learn about
physics, the world around us and more.
And what is perhaps even more important is that I try to teach you a powerful
way of understanding difficult mathematical concepts. Make sure to have a look.
What you see here is a report of this exact paper we have talked about,
which was made by weights and biases. I put a link to it in the description,
make sure to have the look.
I think it helps you understand this paper better weights and biases provides
tools to track your experiments in your deep learning project.
Their system is designed to save you a ton of time and money,
and it is actively used in projects at prestigious labs,
such as open AI Toyota research GitHub and more.
And the best part is that weights and biases is free for all individuals
academics and open source projects. It really is as good as it gets,
make sure to visit them through wnb.com/papers,
or just click the link in the video description.
And you can get the free demo today.
Our thanks to weights and biases for their longstanding support and for helping
us make better videos for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous support. And I'll see you next time.